[Music]
I brought with me her star a star that
she wore before the continent in Holland
but we do Don it for Jew I'm confident
she will come back he's done many things
that many people regard is wrong but the
law distinguishes between sin and crime
could have enough meat for three injured
passengers no longer enjoy the blast but
a good news the impeachment of a
president the case facing Donald Trump
will begin in the Senate later questions
remain though about whether witnesses
will be called and whether mr. Trump
himself will be forced to testify it's
something his lawyer Alan Davis isn't so
keen on he's this big in Disgaea news
about the case he'll put forward in
defense of mr. Trump my wife had great
reluctance and in the end President
Trump spoke to my wife and my wife made
the arguments why I shouldn't do it then
we've had to think this through very
hard as a as a family I'm a liberal
Democrat I voted against President Trump
I will argue that the two articles of
impeachment don't satisfy the
constitutional criteria the
constitutional criteria are treason
nobody has alleged that he's committed
treason bribery although there's been
discussion abrir he wasn't charged with
that or other high crimes and
misdemeanors I interpret other high
crimes and misdemeanors to require
criminal conduct not abuse of power so
are you arguing that even if he has done
something which some people might regard
as wrong it is not impeachable there's
no doubt that he's done many things that
many people regard as wrong but the law
distinguishes between sin and crime
Donald Trump wants to testify do you
think he should know all of my clients
want to testify all the time they want
to tell their story but it's far better
to elect
Constitution in this case the house put
on their case and then let it be
rebutted is it because you think Donald
Trump is a weak witness no I think that
Donald Trump would fill in gaps that's
what happens good
prosecutors asked questions and lay
perjury traps but what about other
witnesses like left honest an associate
of Rudy Giuliani who recently said the
president knew all about the pressure
campaign in Ukraine in the end a lot of
his statements on television are hearsay
or double hearsay but I have no problem
with witnesses coming on if the Senate
decides they want to hear witnesses on
both sides why do you think the
president picked you and what has he
said to you well I can't tell you what
the president said to me but I can tell
you why I think he picked me I had
written two books and many many articles
on why I believe the framers did not
intend abuse of power obstruction of
Congress and other open vague terms to
constitute impeachable offenses I think
the president's read what I've written
he's seen what I've said and it suits
his defense I'm just a part an important
part but a small part of the whole team
I'm making the legal argument he has
other lawyers who will be making the
factual
'lord hall is to resign as the BBC's
director-general after seven years in
the job his departure takes place when
the corporation's future in its current
form is being questioned I think there's
a dangerous period ahead for the BBC
because there are many in government
including the Prime Minister Boris
Johnson who don't really like the idea
of the BBC being funded as a public
service broadcaster through the licence
fee so I think the BBC's got to maintain
and sustain public support and rapidly
get its own house in order I that's
because I've enjoyed it enormously and I
had a great time thank you very much and
one of the things which matters to me is
knowing when the right time is is to go
and I love the organization it's always
going to be difficult to leave but this
is the right moment do you think the
future hold for the oh I think the
future of the BBC and for British
content is great I think the the fact
that we've shown just what a creative
hub we are creative organization we are
in you know the Christmas / New Year you
see the figures now for iPlayer for BBC
sounds it's fantastic and I think we
just got to have the confidence to go
forward in a new world which is always
always changing but as I keep on saying
the arguments for the BBC I think is
stronger now than they've ever been and
I will carry on making those arguments
in the future and whoever takes over for
me I'm sure will make those arguments so
thank you very much I'm all to be done
on the gender pay gap there's always
always more to be done on on change in
the BBC cultural change you know we've
done a lot we are doing a lot and we've
been leading the way in all sorts of
ways but you know you can never stop and
you just got to keep working all the way
okay
at these things right and I'll carry on
for the next six months doing that and
I'm sure my successor will please our to
give road safety training to all staff
at the RF crota Base in Northamptonshire
after the death of Harry Dunne in an
accident nearby the 19 year old died in
a head-on collision where the vehicle
believed to be driven by the wife of a
US diplomat in August of last year at
the weekend police revealed that
diplomatic cars were driven on the wrong
side of the road in two separate
incidents near to the base I speak to
Harry Dunn's parents Charlotte Charles
and turned on we've been hearing from
the local police force in your area
saying the lessons haven't been learned
they're still driving on the wrong side
of the road yeah you know we've we've
been aware of many incidents of this
nature for a while now many many people
are coming forward we feel we have no
choice but to try and make that public
the fact that the Northamptonshire
police are now agreeing to you know work
with the base or the base are now
agreeing to work with them I should say
and accept this driver training is a
good step in the right direction it's a
small step but it's very very much
appreciated step and pretty vital I
think Tim too little too late for your
boy of course she has been certainly
charged over Harry's death causing death
by dangerous driving but the US has
called it highly inappropriate how
hopeful are you that she will be brought
back to the United Kingdom to face
justice yeah I think she has to come
back I don't see how that is a highly
inappropriate but I am confident she
will come back we seen the support from
the country and support we're getting
now from other parts of the government
and the dinah state he is
killed our son by an accident but she
has to answer for that
there could be no reason why that they
can keep her there she needs to come
back to to face what she's done nobody's
above this above the law for killing
somebody so I truly believe that she
will she will come back yes when that
she will be whether it's this
administration or the next we we will
work for as long as we have to to make
sure that she does return here and face
our justice system it's it's the right
thing to do
yeah that's certainly the allegation
against her Charlotte you you did go
over to the White House you met the
president both of you I believe and you
were given the opportunity to meet mrs.
siccola she decided at that time that
you didn't want to how do you feel about
that
no absolutely still stand by our
decision and it was completely and
utterly the wrong environment to have
that thrown upon us and for her and for
us you know we we were open to meeting
her you know we were over there with you
know good intention intentions to plead
with her to come forward to meet us or
to come back to the UK I should say to
meet us and to go through the justice
system but to be thrown into a situation
where we could have potentially met her
we have no therapists around us no
mediators she I believe would have
needed the same
so absolutely we stand by our decision
that we made as a family completely
unhealthy situation for her family for
her and for us definitely now the former
Prime Minister Gordon Brown has warned
that the United Kingdom is at breaking
point he said that too much power is
concentrated in London and called for
the nations and regions to get a real
voice in decision-making well I spoke to
him began by asked him whether he thinks
brexit risks breaking up the United
Kingdom I think getting brexit done is
in danger of leaving Britain undone and
I think we've got to face up to the fact
that unless we change fundamentally our
Constitution Scotland may secede from it
and the regions will feel uncomfortable
within it and I believe that Boris
Johnson cannot just have cosmetic
measures like removing the House of
Lords from London to Birmingham or Leeds
or to York there's got to be substantive
change because what we've seen in the
last few months is people are very fed
up they're fed up with stagnant wages
are very fed up with their public
services that have been deteriorating
that they're fed up also with zero-hour
contracts they're fed up with boarded up
town centres and if we are going to do
something in the regions and in the
nations of the country outside the
centre of London and then the regions
and nations must have a voice that's
what I want to talk about Scottish
independence it's there it's clear
Nicola Sturgeon says the clamor is
growing ever what what if the United
Kingdom changed see this is my point
today that she's assuming she wants a
referendum on Oh change versus
independence what's going to happen in
the next few months is the United
Kingdom is going to be under pressure to
change its own constitution and Scotland
maybe feel far more comfortable within a
United Kingdom that starts to change and
amend and give a voice to the regions as
well as the nations and might be far
more comfortable if the reallocation of
resources in the United Kingdom helps
the outlying areas helps the Midlands
helps the north help Scotland and help
Wales Nicholas Cage is talking about an
independence referendum next year but
there's no case for having a reference
but at that time there's no case because
the two arguments that she put forward
for a referendum have not been met one
was that we had completed and knew what
the relationship with Europe was was
going to be we don't know we know we're
leaving but we don't know what the
future of relationship is not by the
time that her timetable is out of date
we will still not have had a agreement
on what the future relationship with
Europe is so that argument has fallen
she then said that she would have a
referendum if she would have a
consistent majority of support in
Scotland for independence and there is
no such majority in Scotland at the
moment that's either been consistent or
decisive or overwhelming in fact there
is no consensus on it and it's a divided
Scotland on these issues
well events are taking place across the
world over the next few days marking the
75th anniversary of the liberation of
Auschwitz UNESCO is holding a day of
commemoration in Paris in memory of the
victims of the Nazi concentration camp
and of course next week its Holocaust
Memorial Day well joining me now is
little Finkelstein Daniel Finkelstein
his mother major was held at
bergen-belsen but survived the Holocaust
she died in 2017 and noticed that you
said on social media you were going to
talk about your mother yes this week in
her experiences why well because this
week is the 75th anniversary of them
being on an exchange my mother her two
sisters and her mother on an exchange
from Berlin which is very rare fifty
thousand people died in Belsen in the
end partly because Asterix was liberated
and people came from Auschwitz as the
Allies advanced and the Russians
advanced they came into the middle of
Germany not from lots of different
concentration camps and ended up in
Belsen which couldn't cope with it and
lots of people died of typhus like Anne
Frank did my mother was fortunate after
about a couple of months of that she was
on an exchange only 300 people were ever
exchanged from what was supposed to be
an exchange camp but she had some faith
exchange meaning it means that she had
shared fake basically or false
Paraguayan Passport and people who had
those were able to be exchanged for
Germans who lived in our Allied occupied
countries it was a I said they were able
to in fact it hard
we happened 136 people with that sort of
documentation were ultimately released
to Switzerland my mother was fortunate
enough to be one of them that meant that
in those last very last few months the
the family wasn't there anymore although
my grandma was already ill enough that
unfortunately when she arrived in
Switzerland saw the girls to freedom
later this week 75 years ago later this
week she died that night and what was
the experience of your mother's family
in the Nazi people well my grandfather
was one of the great was one of the
leaders of the German Jewish community
and one of the archivists of the
anti-nazi movement he moved his archive
to Holland and then he had to move it to
London he opened it at the beginning of
the war but unfortunately when he sent
back visas for his family they didn't
arrive in time so they were trapped in
Holland
eventually they were taken to the vest
abort transit camp from which most
people ended up in Auschwitz also people
including my mother's arms but my mother
and her sisters and my grandmother ended
up in Belsen and and this is obviously
75th anniversaries it was 3/4 century
it's a milestone but do you feel that we
are forgetting well actually I'm a bit
more optimistic than that I think we're
beginning to remember because when my
mother really came people to America ask
you where she was people want to know
she came from Holland did she wear clogs
but they didn't know anything about the
concentration camps sometimes where she
came to this country she would at a
dinner or something she would happen to
mention her past and people were
completely amazed by it because nobody
talked about it and it wasn't I'm
actually conscious really of the first
time my mother began to talk about it in
public not because she didn't talk about
it she was very open about it but
because people weren't that interested
and so she began to tell her story she
went to lots of schools I brought
actually with with me her star the star
that she wore in the concentration camp
not before the concentration camp in
Holland with you'd on it for Jew the
yellow star which which my mother always
said they had to actually pay for those
if they had to pay for them there to pay
to buy these stars and then sew them on
themselves
extraordinary and it was an offensive
but it was an offensive you did not have
it yes and ultimately those I say they
were arrested they went to serve Esther
bought but I do think people are taking
an interest in this because there's a
recognition of the value of the the sort
of demonstration that the Holocaust
makes of the value of liberal
democracies and therefore people are
increasingly keen to talk about what
happened now the sad news we brought you
earlier on the death of Monty Python
starts Harry Jones at the age of 77 his
family released a statement saying that
he had been fighting a long extremely
brave but always good humoured battle
with a rare form of dementia or fellow
Python John Cleese has been leading the
tributes to Terry Jones remarkable
fellow because he had endless energy and
enthusiasm we all almost used to laugh
at him sometimes I remember he got up
one day when we were shooting on the
south coast he got excited about how
green but grass was you see what I mean
so that there was this hugely lively
energy in him which was very very
attractive it is a sad day but the warm
memories and the laughs that's what
gives me great pleasure remembering the
times we all had we were a whole gang
who wrote for David Frost
Tyson before they were Python and the
goodies before they were the goodies and
that's when we all met up together
Mike Palin and Terry Jones you know and
grown Chapman and John Cleese and so on
and we were a gang and Terry was an
amazing lively member of the gang and
then emerged as a very talented director
of course subsequently working on the
Python films Life of Brian Holy Grail
now for something completely different
he was just a joy to work with David
Frost he got us all together from all
sorts of places I've been writing for
nightclubs and all sorts and he saw me
once and they now and became part of the
gang and we'd all get together in the
room
you indicated whole gang was now we'd
all play football with the tennis ball
in this church hall and the atmosphere
was just amazing and we all wrote alone
you would pair off with various people
writing together and it was a communal
effort and one of the happiest times of
my life and Terry was part of it the
genius who bought us the thick of it
Amanda unique she has been imagining
what tourism might be like in space what
would happen when five thousand people
are stranded for three and a half years
in a luxury space cruiser bridge crew
listen up
I need a course back to earth there's a
lot of people counting on us to get them
there
everything is fine we have an update for
three injured passengers no longer enjoy
the blast but a good news it's set in
the world of space tourism in 40 years
time and there's these fleet of
spaceships owned by a guy called Herman
chard and he's named them after famous
streets in Manhattan so there's Avenue
for there's Broadway
there's Lexington Avenue five and it's
the maiden trip to Saturn and back
normally takes eight weeks five thousand
passengers one and a half thousand Crowe
something goes wrong it's hurting much
longer than that maybe years
so you're then faced with the question
what does six and a half thousand people
who have nothing in common other than
that they are trapped on a massive
luxury hotel what do they do and how do
they go about it's really it's really
about how do you it's like Lord of the
Flies of course a comedy but it's so
it's dramatic there's elements of drama
amongst it there is watching the
genuinely thinking what's gonna happen
yes I've kind of structured in a way
that every episode aims on a bit of a
cliffhanger or a major revelation or or
a twist really because I kind of like
that and maybe it's my experience of
working on HBO that you know they're
there thing is we want to make people we
don't stream all the episodes at once
they want people to come back the
following week how do we do that and it
allows you to start thinking about not
just the episode but the series as a
whole and do something a bit more
interesting
let's say about a man who has been
sitting in a barrel suspended some 80
feet above ground for more than two
months who has just made it into the
Guinness World Record book and not for
the first before the second time this is
Vernon Krueger
who was broken the world record for
remaining in a barrel at the top of a
pole from dual stream in South Africa
further welcome to you you get you're
already giving us a view of your view
eighty or so feet above the ground there
is only one question tell us why no
really I've forgotten why actually
forgotten since I've been yet I'm
attempting to break my own world record
well I have broken it now 22 years ago I
am I set the record that was actually a
British record which I broke was 54 days
you know I took it to 67 and this time
I'm probably going to try and push it to
about 80 if possible what's different
this time is we have social media as I
feel quite connected to the rest of the
world yeah I can I can look at the
people below and I talk to people all
day long so it's not really that cut off
from the world as one would imagine I do
exercises in the morning I have a
someone that leads me in exercises from
below the pole so I do get enough
exercise I can stand up and I can
stretch off your body sticks out when I
stand up but it's not very big it's 500
liters I can just curl up in a fetal
position so I do wake up with a lot of
aches and pains share the view with us
get and stretch your legs while you're
at it don't get to touch the edge I've
got the flag of course it's taking up a
lot of space
just know where the wreck rubies oh yeah
this is what that's like
and anybody anybody watching you Burgin
oh no sit down sit down bonus yeah